death is inevitable at least for the
individual whether you're getting
consumed or your environment poisons you
or you fall apart as time marches on we
die but our genes fellow-traveller our
genes often survive because we living
things we reproduce and while humans
with our experience of plants and
animals are of course most familiar with
sexual reproduction as we do it that is
absolutely not the only way it can be
done by this point on your journey you
should already know that nothing is
usual in the micro cosmos
most unicellular reproduction is asexual
meaning one organism on its own can
reproduce itself the most common form of
asexual reproduction and the one you are
most likely to know about in the macro
cosmos is binary fission one organism
simply divides into two unicellular
organisms of course do not have genders
but by custom the dividing cell is
called the mother while the cells formed
after division are called daughters this
is a Helios OA on amoeboid cell with
stiff arms called AXA podía radiating
from its spherical body here it
undergoes binary fission to create two
daughter cells watch as these two future
daughters move in opposing directions
with the help of AXA podía until the
cytoplasmic bridge that was formed
between them is finally cut off
[Music]
now which of these two cells is the
original and which is the offspring and
the micro cosmos that's not always how
it works
both of these Helios OA are daughters
and the mother has ceased existing
either that or the mother is now both of
them and if that is the case every
single celled organism is itself the
same organism that has continued
surviving since the very first cell
reproduced itself billions of years ago
but like we don't want to hurt your
brain too early in the episode so it's
probably best not to think about it too
much the process of binary fission
happens fairly quickly all things
considered but of course we have to
speed up the tape a bit for you to enjoy
it here a photosynthetic flagella called
you Glenna disease is dividing the
nucleus however has already divided and
each of these halves has its own control
center even though the cytoplasm is
still joined which makes you wonder are
these two separate organisms now where
are they only individuals once their
membranes separate
[Music]
now we're pretty sure this organism is
Scifo Daria but it's a little hard to be
sure especially during the reproduction
process but it is definitely some kind
of testate amoebae which are amoeba that
builds cells for themselves to live in
that protect them from predators and
just the world which can be a rough
place you might think that they like
snails or clams build these shells
around themselves after they're born and
that is true for some test data moebus
but not for this one during cell
division Scifo Daria actually builds a
second shell and then squirts new cell
material into that shell to create its
daughters
[Music]
ciliates like Paramecium and Stentor
actually have two types of nuclei macro
nucleus and a micro nucleus the macro
nucleus controls the non reproductive
cell functions like eating movement and
digestion and the micro nucleus is
necessary for reproduction these nuclei
actually divide differently during
reproduction and for certain ciliates
the micro nucleus plays a truly bizarre
role but to talk about that we need to
move away from asexual reproduction
which so far is all we've talked about
and it's fine we guess but in all of
these cases each daughter cell is a
clone of the mother in sexual
reproduction genes can flow much more
easily through populations which has a
huge evolutionary advantage but sexual
reproduction and the micro cosmos is not
like sexual reproduction for the rest of
us
[Music]
conjugation requires two cells first to
ciliates become attached to each other
by their oral surface micro nuclei in
the ciliates then divide several times
in each cell and then one micro nucleus
from each cell moves into the other cell
and fuses with the micro nucleus there
the macro nuclei of both cells then
dissolves into the cytoplasm each cell
now has a brand new genome it is as if
you gave someone a kiss and walked away
a genetically different person there are
no children the gene transfer happens to
the existing organism now after
separation the cells produce new micro
and macro nuclei and then reproduce
asexually until each daughter cell has
the correct number of macro and micro
nuclei for their species conjugation is
thus considered a sexual phenomenon
which is immediately followed by
repeated asexual reproduction this can
be hard to get your brain around because
to us the exchange of genetic
information is so deeply tied with the
creation of new offspring that in the
micro cosmos you can see genetic
exchange is possible without
reproduction
if I were to tell you that this is only
the very surface of the iceberg of
complexity of reproduction in the micro
cosmos I hope that by this point you
would believe me because it is these
beautiful bags of chemicals have to
continue existing and they have done so
elegantly using strategies that to us
might seem counterintuitive but are
nevertheless the simplest and most
effective ways for keeping their genes
alive and it's hard to fault them for it
it's been working for them for billions
of years while you and I of
fellow-traveller have only been here for
a blink so thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
James check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
you